the way I like to eat is really focused
around creating and maintaining the type
and physique that I've personally found
to be the most optimal to the
disciplines that I want to be able to
perform and this is by no means a
perfect diet or me suggesting to you
something that you should be doing it's
just basically a breakdown of what I've
been doing and the things that are
working for me currently this video is
going to be mainly focused upon the
philosophy behind why I choose to eat
this way as well as like a bit of a
brief overview of how I consume our
meals throughout the day and things like
that
it's a metaphor that has been used
pretty extensively but a good way to
describe but this philosophy would be
like that of a high-performance vehicle
the demands that are placed on it a far
higher than that of a normal vehicle so
it has to be specifically treated and
maintained similarly I put my body
through a physical stress on a regular
basis and so the same goes accordingly
things like sleeping adequately
maintaining mobility and of course a
nutrition plan that suits the outcome of
which you're aiming and this leads me to
my next point which is it's critical to
be very clear upon the goal of what
you're aiming so that you know the
things that you need to do to achieve it
pretty simple so for the sake of ease
we'll call this our North Star in
business the North Star means pretty
much the company's purpose so that they
know the best ROI actions to be done to
achieve it but the metaphor works really
well here too now for me these fall into
two main areas number one has been in an
optimal place physically to perform the
way 1 as a martial artist and that's
keeping my body condition to a level
where it's light and agile well having a
level of strength to be able to deliver
how.what adequately and these also
connecting to many other beneficial
areas of performance such as speed
explosiveness and cardiovascular
capacity number 2 is to promote
longevity I want to be able to make the
maximum use of my body for as long as
I'm capable I want to be able to Train
forever so I tried to take as good care
of myself as possible using the
modalities that I'm able to influence
and when I talk about knowing your
outcome it might sound like common sense
but if you look around most gyms there's
always a big contradiction in the
rationale of most people's methods and
their behavior that into use so for
instance somebody might state that they
wish to improve their skills in martial
arts but at the same time they don't
want to let go of their bodybuilding
training for instance and you know adopt
something that will be more beneficial
to improve your martial arts and you can
certainly take this approach if you want
and become
a kind of jack-of-all-trades and many
people do like this approach but we only
have a finite amount of energy and when
you do focus on lots of different things
this is where your energy goes you make
progress outwardly say you expend your
energy and make a little bit of progress
in lots of things whereas if you remove
the majority of these things and just
focus on one or very few areas your
progress becomes exponential and it's
really ridding yourself of the most
trivial things and focusing upon the
essentials to reach the goal that you're
after and what I found for me is to keep
things really simple as you've probably
well know gimmicky diet fads
overwhelmingly promising magic pill
solutions so I would recommend finding
something that works for you personally
and even though there's a lot of really
confusing information out there there's
really no secret to nutrition and most
people who are kind of doing anything
related to any kind of performance of
the body tend to eat really similar
things if you do your research but it's
easy to see why people think so when you
come across articles like this of course
Ronaldo is in good shape but you know he
just eats healthy and trains there's not
really any magic or secret and I've
tried many different things out but what
I found works best is that I found a
selection of foods and dishes that I
really like and basically pretty much
eat the same thing every single day and
if you pretty much hate what you're
eating but you're doing it to achieve a
certain result then long-term that's not
going to work so I think it's vital to
enjoy what you're eating so it can be
sustainable for you going forwards your
hands greasy no seasoning this is
dreadful I also follow practices that
you've most likely heard before like
eating foods that are as close to their
natural source as possible and not
eating anything too overly processed I
also don't really like to put on too
many condiments and sauces and things
like that I find you're sticking to
herbs and spices to be pretty much
sufficient and I also don't really
consume empty calories like sodas and
other beverages that just have high
calories and lots of sugar and things
like that in them and this isn't for
everyone but one thing I do do every day
is track and weigh everything that I eat
to make sure that it fits my
macronutrient breakdown now this may
sound like a bit of an odd thing to do
after I just said in the previous
statement that I pretty much eat the
same foods every day but for me it's
more like an exercise in discipline and
a kind of trick of the mind and when I
do this it has multiple benefits so one
is obviously ensuring that consuming the
macros are one which I know produces a
certain look and feel to my physique but
more importantly than that
gives me the feeling of being kind of on
track and being on top of things and you
know being more kind of like the person
I envisioned myself to be my kind of
best self if that makes sense now we
don't have control of many areas of our
life a lot of things are out of our
control poor nutrition is one area that
you can control so I like to take
advantage of that and in doing this also
has knock-on effects to other areas of
life like you know knowing that you can
set a target stick to something and
achieve a result at the end which i
think is really important I feel this is
why training in general and for me the
martial arts mirrors life in so many
ways and carries principles that can be
applied in so many other areas so my
height is five foot seven and my weight
is around one hundred and forty pounds
right now and I'm quite lean it this
weight which is more a personal
preference for me but going back to that
performance car analogy they don't
really contain any unnecessary luxuries
because they are made for a purpose and
similarly I don't really like to have
any excess weight on my frame and we
know that having extra you know baggage
you could call it leads to things like
insulin resistance inflammation and
numerous other negative effects so I
like to try and keep my body weight
relatively low and not fluctuate too
much which can be managed through
tracking and just on a side note looking
back at Ronaldo again he apparently
plans to lose a kilogram just over two
pounds of weight per year in order to
maintain or extend his career and this
is also something that I've noticed
about Zlatan Ibrahimovic as well is that
recently he seems to really have trimmed
his weight down and he's still playing
at the highest level at age 38 which is
incredibly rare for that sport so
there's clearly something in this about
obviously having a lighter weight or
trimming your weight back and it being
less stressful on the body long-term so
a general overview of how I do things as
well as ye is the following the first
thing I'll do upon waking up is have a
black coffee followed by a huge load of
water throughout the morning and
sometimes I'll chop a lemon into this
water as well
fasting has been found to have longevity
benefits because of its effects on
things like Auto Fuji which is the
body's way of removing damaged cells so
our tough OG
literally means to self eat and in dr.
David Sinclair's book life span he cites
that it was initially thought that
simple caloric restriction was what
caused the increase in life of test
subjects but it was later discovered
that similar effects could be gained
using fast in which he explains in
laymen terms as kind of turning
your longevity genes and before II
anything most days I'll do some kind of
fasted circuit training for about half
an hour total and this is purely for
maintaining a level of conditioning for
me but also many of the movements use
the whole body so it lends itself well
to martial arts training as opposed to
some other training methods that simply
train you to be adaptive on one plane of
movement the level to which I train here
isn't quite the intensity of hit but
it's definitely challenging enough to do
what I need it to do while avoiding over
stress in my body and nervous system so
much that it would take away from my
main goal of being a better martial
artist and this is something that I've
built up to over time and I wouldn't
recommend to just jump in with a similar
workload to what I'm accustomed to
Sinclair also states in his book that
intense exercise that leaves you
breathless is also the best promoter of
longevity so you can see how here once
again there's many of the things that
I'm doing have dual functions so killing
two birds with one stone if you will and
I don't follow a strict fasting and eat
in window there's a few different ones
like the twelve twelve with the most
popular one being the 16-hour fast and
eight hour eaten window but I generally
tend to eat my first meal around 1 p.m.
which is eggs and spinach with sourdough
toast a - sourdough toast because it's
known to be better for digestion and
some of the breads can lead to bloating
and things like that a little bit later
on I'll have yogurt with some various
ingredients such as berries and protein
powder and with the lockdown currently
occurring the way I train has changed a
bit from being able to visit the gym so
in the evening at the minute I'll
usually just train some techniques and
do some stretching
whereas before I'd usually have my main
session in the evening which would vary
between train and alone at my local gym
or with friends somewhere else and this
has changed how I eat a little in the
afternoon as well because when I would
train with friends for instance out of
eating something more beforehand as the
sessions were usually over a couple of
hours and pretty intense but now I'll
just have some fruit or something else
alight and then a larger meal again
after I train after this training
session I tend to have a really big meal
that contains salmon rice or pasta green
vegetables avocado lentils and some of
the vegetables if I have them lying
around then finally I'll have some kind
of medieval snack which will be like
sourdough toast again with peanut butter
and banana or sweet potato and avocado
and anything else that I may need to
make up my calories so I know that might
sound pretty simple but that's what I've
kind of found works best when
and before I started taking training
really seriously I just used to kind of
eat whatever but I definitely noticed
improvements and way more benefits since
really dialing things in like this and
if I've been training particularly hard
over a period of time I'll notice maybe
a dip in energy and a spike in hunger
and when this happens I made his head to
have a day where I at least 1,000 extra
calories mainly from low GI carb sources
and that kind of sorts me out and makes
me feel pretty good other than that I
tend to not really have that much else
unless I'm going out to kind of a
restaurant or something like that but if
I'm going somewhere I'll tend to prepare
something beforehand and take it with me
so that I don't really have to eat
anything too overly processed and once
every now and then I'll have a cheap
meal or you know a few cheap meals or
something like that I used to have like
a full day of doing this where I'd have
a full kind of cheat day but I found
that the next day it like severely
wrecked my mood and made me really kind
of like agitated and cranky and stuff so
I tried to limit it and not go too
overboard with that anymore and as
mentioned previously you know I'm not
telling you this is like the optimal
diet I think you should do your own
research and learn what may work for you
and try different things so you can find
it out that's what I did and it's not
only really good form for I think it's a
really important skill to know you know
like I think nutrition should actually
be taught in schools most people have
kind of no clue what they're putting
into their bodies and what they think is
healthy is actually really often
unhealthy and worse than that they're
obviously given those foods to their
families and things like that as well so
learning some information about
nutrition even basic knowledge about how
to read food labels and things I think
is super important remember Ted to my
channel as well youtube.com slash Grand
Stephens MA I will be getting around to
making other content on there as well I
know I keep talking about it but I've
had quite a lot of different things on
at the minute so it's trying to find
time to prioritize doing that as well as
these videos and other things I've got
going on so I will be doing that and
also subscribe to my other social media
channels like Instagram or post videos
on their different workouts and things
I'm doing and you can follow through
with those as well thanks for watching
guys and I'll see you next time